frédéric dabi il ya quand même un
paradoxe il ya une majorité de français
qui semblent mécontente de cette de
cette réforme du code du travail
et pourtant il n'y a pas énormément de
monde dans les manifs de la cgt c'est
pas la foule des grands jours dans l'est
dans les rassemblements autour de
mélenchon et là le blocage des routes
hier d'avoir du mal à prendre
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous avez raison
on a les mêmes critiques entre cette loi
sur le cas du travail et que ce qu'on
voyait au moment de la loi elle comrie
le sentiment d'une loi déséquilibrée et
injuste qui favorise plus hauts
dirigeants d'entreprises que la
protection des salariés
pour autant il ya une question de cas
est une question de calendrier de tempo
ça arrive en début de mandat cette
réforme était quand même dans l'offre
programmatique présidentielle d'emmanuel
macron un peu comme ce qu'on ait réussi
à faire celui qu' il va appeler le faux
dur nicolas sarkozy en début de mandat
avec la loi tepa avec la réforme des
régimes spéciaux il ya eu quand même des
très fortement et extrêmement suivi
beaucoup plus ou beaucoup plus fortement
suivie que ce qu'on a eu ces dernières
semaines je pense que c'est ça qui
permet à emmanuel macron en plus deux
d'incarner celui qui peut réussir à
transformer le pays et appliquer son
programme je le répète c'est
complètement inédit dans les enquêtes de
l'ifop depuis de très nombreuses années
de voir comme ressort de satisfaction à
l'égard du chef d'état il va faire ce
qu'il a dit il a dit ce qu'il va faire
et d'ailleurs est en train de remonter
dans les sondages
je fais référence à cela il a repris 5
points ce qui est rare au mois de
septembre qui en plus une valve de
rentrée il ya toujours des impatiences
des frustrations et des mécontentements